hallo matt komm hallo klick zoom und
megan hast du einen flashmob
emotional berührt oder ging es nur ums geld
danke im voraus warum er fragt wenn ja
ich frage dich okay wenn sie mich gefragt hat und
dann hab ich dich gefragt hast du hast du getan
Hat mich das Flashmob-Ding getroffen, weil es
emotional war, oder hast du es wegen des Geldes getan?
Nein, Mann, nicht wegen des Geldes, aber nicht einmal
Geld für den Flashmob bekommen
was ich habe wenig
geld es für mich zu essen wenn du
danach darüber redest nein nein wenn du nein sagst wirst du
für mich arbeiten wo ist es ich weiß nicht
du teilst nicht sie haben mir für
einen fall gegeben a  gut und sehr gut dr.  Schmied
Krebs bei mir also dein Weg Problem nein
für mich nicht für Geld für ihn du rufst
sie an jetzt verkaufen okay HSV Tante du bist
aus Hamburg unterstütze deine Stadt